hi I'm Megan good and I'm Michael Haley
and we're here at BuzzFeed we're gonna
rain thirst tweets I'm a little bit
nervous yeah cuz they're just there when
we're getting on the elevator Michael
goes I'm like no yeah we are going to
start with Michael's first tweets I'm
sorry but I would look everything on
Michael Lee's body Wow
okay yeah yeah just hold on to this okay
this is so festive I don't want to keep
this Wow okay
uh I want Michael Ealy to give me a
mammogram with his penis you said that
on chance I sure did um I would do the
dirtiest things with Michael Ealy dirty
things those those were capital yeah
dirty dirty thing I don't know the penal
mana grant ma'am yeah that's the move
yeah I was gonna stick with me yeah yeah
that was like that's very creative
I just know Michael Ealy tastes like
butter pecan ice cream don't know how I
taste but okay Michael Ealy eat me alive
well now that is out there now so I
could do like like a like a white Walker
kind of thing yeah yeah you know I have
blue eyes so true I could see a white
what happened I think there's a lot of
confidence on Twitter because no one
says this to you to your face you know
to me like can you give me a penal
mammogram yeah I'm still stuck on that
word yeah because it's yeah it's just
like howdy
I got a have to yeah that's what I'm
saying - looking Michael Ealy has
officially been added to my bucket list
that's working licky yeah
fishing and I guarantee if I meet her
she won't do it Wow yeah I get some
security I guess
dear Michael Ealy I want to bear your
children or at least do the walk of
shame from your house love sleep alright
I like that one yeah the walk is saying
join the crew there's no shame I want
Michael alien to grind in my face
Wow Pony by Ginuwine plays in the
background jump on it did I already
mentioned that I want Michael Ealy
inside me because I want me Michael
elite inside me yeah yeah she said it
twice yes she did inside her did she
mention okay so that was uncomfortable
but kind of Awesome
so here's the thing I'm about to read
first tweets for you make it and I'm
gonna do him in my deep voice just so
you know I'd sell my gallbladder a
kidney and half a lung to watch Meghan
good eat a sandwich through a pair of
binoculars who do you say what kind of
sandwich he don't even wanna be next to
you he wants to be like sniper distance
and watching you with binoculars eat a
sandwich it's Johnny
I would get baptized and Meghan good
sweat he wants to be baptized in your
sweat if you're funky or not Oh what
what is happening this is gonna this
this right okay um
I will eat Meghan with a soup spoon
what I don't know why wrong spoon okay
here's here's a little funny one right I
imagine Megan good taste like that
secret water Bobby Boucher had on water
boy okay
oh sweet thank you yes right that but do
you have to keep saying like that the
deep voice is funny Megan good can get
it right now
and tomorrow she should've got it
yesterday too wide covered all bases and
he says with a deep oh yes yes three
days at her oh baby don't we that's
healthy yes Megan good nips have a touch
in mind I swear I would have a heart
attack I can tell that grammar doesn't
amount to much on wait yeah you know
it's it's about the space either like
like like he didn't get the possessive s
after your last name they just went
making my lips yeah that's true but Lisa
spell my name right as as someone who
had to kiss Megan for the movie I didn't
have a heart attack so I guess we're
different seeing Megan good lick her
lips equals vision oh my
I've read of different words of the bag
that's less bad what you thought you
that's some real fans out there
yes I want Megan to sit on my face I
want Megan good to cook me a grilled
cheese sandwich with some leather chaps
off with the Butchie out the butt cheek
out he went slightly doublet hey hey why
don't they capitalize in an explosion
my name is thought in a gan Oh God
first tweets were Thursday first tweets
what was your favorite one I've already
blocked most amount of written right oh
I know your favorite one who was the
mama cry mama credit with Athena I
appreciate the love and the support our
educational system is clearly failing
our children so we wanted to say thank
you so much BuzzFeed I'm making good and
I am Michael Ealy thirsty tweets and
please don't see the intruder May 3rd in
theaters everywhere
[Music]